>> Michelle Loyalka: Thank you everybody for
coming.
It's great to be here and to have the chance
to share with you a bit about what I've learned
in researching and writing this book and also
living in China for the last 15 years.
As the David, and as the subtitle of the book
suggests this is really a work about the massive
movement of people from the countryside in
China to the urban centers and right now there's
about 200 million people at any given time,
in, from the countryside who are in the cities
and that number is expected to grow to about
300 million people within the next 20 years.
And so that makes it really the fastest and
the largest movement of people in human history.
It's really having a dramatic impact on China
in terms of attitudes and values and standard
of living and lifestyles and social dynamics,
everything is changing because of this movement.
And also, it's creating a bit of, a sort of
unrest and upheaval, so it's really emerging
in China these days, as the key issue, the
key domestic issue that the Chinese government
is trying to tackle.
So what I wanted to do today was give you
first a little bit of an overview of sort
of the scale of what's happening and then
we can talk more about the issues in the book.
So if we look in terms of urbanization, so
western countries generally took about 200
years to make that switch from being primarily
urban, or rural societies to primarily urban
societies.
And China is on track to make this transition
within about 50 years.
And in the 30 years since China started its
opening and reform policies, its urban population
has double and in the next 30 years, it's
expected to double yet again.
So by comparison, Europe currently has 35
cities with more than a million people and
China right now has about 160, but by 2025,
it's expected that China will have 221 cities
with more than a million people, so that makes
Europe look small by comparison.
[chuckles] Among these 221 cities will be
15 super cities, each with about 25 million
people, so by comparisons the entire state
of Texas has about 25 million people so that
will be 15 cities in China each as large as
the state of Texas.
And by 2030, China's urban population will
reach 1 billion people, so urban China will
be more populous than the North and South
American continents combined, so obviously
this is a very large movement of people and
it's happening very quickly and there's a
lot of different factors sort of underlying
this transition.
But the people really at the heart of it are
China's s rural migrants.
So again, I said there's about 200 million
migrants now and there will be about 300 million
within the next 20 years.
And I think in the west people tend to think
of China's migrants mostly as factory workers,
but in fact of the 200 million migrants that
are out there right now only about a third
of them work in factories.
The rest of them are intimately involved in
every aspect of building up urban China and
driving this urbanization.
So, for example, over the next 20 years migrants
will help to build 5 million new buildings
including 50,000 sky scrapers or the equivalent
of 10 New York cities.
And they'll also help to pave 5 million square
meters of roads.
And they tend to go into the cities in China
and snap up sort of the low paying, dirty,
dangerous, distasteful jobs that urbanites
are not really so interested in.
And they also carve out for themselves all
sorts of different small time entrepreneurial
niches.
Some people may haul heavy loads, they may
do repair work; sell produce on the street
corner.
The man at the top here, he's popping popcorn,
so there's sort of all sorts of things people
do and generally they tend to be very light
on their feet and able to sort of quickly
remold themselves to meet the changing needs
of the Chinese economy.
And so, I met, in the course of the research
I did for the book, I met many people who
within just the scope of a year or two had
sort of continually reinvented themselves
time and again.
So one woman had gone from selling eggs on
the street corner, to selling produce, to
shining shoes, to running a small shop and
I looked at that and how quickly she could
change directions, I felt amazed, sort of
by that ability.
She said, "This is the way you do things when
you don't have a lot of other options."
And so as a result of this, urban China really
couldn't function without migrant labor.
I had this idea to do a blog post about how
much the average urbanite's life depends on
migrants.
I live in Beijing now, so I had the idea I'd
just take a picture of each person and write
a couple of lines about what they were doing
in the city.
And by the time I left my house in the morning
and got to the subway stop, which usually
is about a 20-minute walk, I gave up because
it was taking the whole day.
There was just so many migrants that my life
depends on in the cities that it was became
a sort of overwhelming project.
But in addition to that, migrants are really
essential to building up China's rural areas
as well.
Because the money that migrants send back
to the villages, in lots of places, really
is the major portion of local income and so
they're really responsible for raising rural
China out of poverty as well.
So, I want to tell you a little bit, about
how I came to write about this topic.
When I went to China in 1997, I wasn't a journalist
at that time, I first worked in education
and I had a lot of different opportunities.
And one of them was I worked on this curriculum
for children to learn English.
And it was used in small towns around Guangdong
Province.
And I would go and visit these schools about
once a month to sort of track their progress
and give some teacher training.
And in one of the schools, the principal invited
me to go with her to stay an extra day and
go with her to back to her village where her
relatives still lived.
And so having lived in urban China for almost
two years at that point and really sometimes
you don't see much grass or trees or any nature
at all [chuckles].
And so I really jumped at the opportunity
and went back with her.
It was a banana farming village in the mountains
and we had a great day hiking and doing things
like that.
And at the end of the day, we were with her
relatives and they asked, "How did you like
our village?"
And I kind of gushed and I said, "Oh, it's
fantastic, I love it here!"
And they said, "Well if you like it so much
why don't you move here?"
And I think looking back, I don't think they
were probably sincerely inviting me as much
as they were making polite, small talk.
But in my enthusiasm, I said "Oh, I would
love to!"
And so that what's I did.
So about a month later I moved to this village.
And it was really a very interesting experience.
It definitely that there had been a foreign
person in the village much less living in
the village.
So very quickly, I became the local tourist
destination.
[laughter] And people from the surrounding
villages would walk to this village; in fact,
someone came from about 20 kilometers away
one time, on foot, to sort of verify is it
really true that there's a foreigner living
here.
[laughter] This is in the south of China were
it's very hot and so the windows are always
open, but there's bars, everyone has bars
on the windows.
And so people would come and stand outside
the window of my house with their hands on
the bars and sort of stare in and watch me
and have this ongoing commentary with each
other about what they saw the foreigner doing.
It was really a very interesting experience,
[laughs] but very wonderful.
And the people especially were very sincere
and very hospitable.
And this was really I think pivotal in terms
of helping me to think about China's rapid
development from the point of view of the
rural people because so of what we see in
the media here is at least is sort of a boomtowns
where everything is going very well in China.
So this gave me a foundation, I think, for
for the book.
And this is another picture of the village
it was called the Flower Fruit Village.
And from there I moved to Xi'an, which is
the ancient capital of China and it's most
well known in the US for being the home to
the terracotta soldiers.
And it's also in western China which has been
the least developed and the poorest part of
China.
And in fact, when China started its opening
and reforms three decades ago they had this
concept basically that they would allow a
small part of the population first to become
prosperous and that those people then would
pull everyone else up to prosperity.
And so eastern China, the sort of crescent
along the seaboard there was chosen to lead
everybody else to prosperity.
And western China was just sort of ignored,
largely, for several decades and languished
behind the rest of the country.
And so I moved to Xi'an in 1999 and in January
of 2000, the country, the government launched
what's called the 'Go West' policy.
And that essentially was designed to help
western China catch up with the rest of the
country, because the gap between the two had
really become unmanageable at that point.
And so when the Chinese government decides
to do something, sometimes it happens extremely
quickly and so within months of that policy
opening, money came pouring into the the city
of Xi'an and especially the high techs zones,
there was what's called the high tech zone,
which is where I was living at that time.
And so from my window in my apartment in the
high tech zone, at any given time, I would
look out and there would be 15 to 20 cranes
on the horizon putting up new urban developments.
But what there also was, what I could also
see really basically behind my apartment complex,
was this old village called Gan Jia Zhai.
This is actually the village whose land the
high tech zone was built on.
So what happens in China, is that as the urban
areas expand, the local city governments will
buy up the neighboring farmland but they don't
generally buy up the cluster of village homes.
And so the farmers who lose their land in
this process, they take whatever money they're
paid for their land and they tend to use that
to build on to their homes, or sometimes they
gut their homes, basically, and start again.
And then they rent out their homes, room by
room, to the migrants to come into the new
up and coming urban areas looking for work.
And so this is extremely common in China,
it's so common that there's a term for it,
which is 'City Village'.
And these City Villages, you'll see them in
any every city in China, basically, and they're
really the way that China has sort of avoided
the absolute poverty, urban slums like you
might see in India or Brazil or other countries.
Because they provide such a sort of critical,
low cost housing alternative for migrants,
they tend to be very densely populated.
So this village was originally home to about
1500 farmers and when I was living there,
they estimated there was about 30,000 migrants
sandwiched into six blocks.
So it's a very high population density and
then, of course, a lot of social problems
follow follow along as well.
In 2004, --so I lived there from '99 to 2004--,
and then I went back.
I came back to the US for grad school and
I did a masters in journalism and when I graduated
I received a fellowship to work at a Book
Link project.
So I knew that I wanted to write about all
the transformation I had experienced in China.
So I went back to that same neighborhood where
I had lived before and what I had found was
that the City Village of Gan Jai Zhai was
about to be demolished.
Everybody that I worked, that I interacted
with regularly, you know the people who I
bought vegetables from or who worked in restaurants,
the security guards, everybody was very anxious,
was upset about this because they lived in
this village and there weren't many more of
these villages left and they weren't sure
once these were gone, how could they support
their life in the city anymore.
And so that really became the backdrop for
the book.
Essentially, in the book, you'll find 8 different
profiles of migrants who have come from different
places in rural China into Xi'an and they
find work in the high tech zone, they live
in this old City Village and the book really
kind of chronicles how successfully, --or
in some cases unsuccessfully--, they're able
to integrate into urban life and enjoy the
fruits of their labors.
And also, how well they're able to accomplish
the goals that they've set out for themselves.
Now, in addition, to that what I try to capture
in the book is also the spirit of the people,
because I think that a lot of times the sort
of story line that you see in the media about
rural people in China is that they're downtrodden
victims of oppression, that sort of concept.
And that's not my experience with them and
I don't think that that's really the way that
most migrants view their own reality.
I think that overall they tend to be pretty
upbeat given the situation they're in, they're
pretty upbeat and optimistic about their future.
And they're extremely enterprising; they find
lots of ways to solve problems that I would've
given up on long ago.
And in Chinese, as David mentioned, there's
this great word, which essentially doesn't
translate directly into English, but it essentially
means to endure hardship, to persevere, and
to just sort of keep moving ahead without
complaining.
So for lack of a better word in English, if
you translate it directly, it comes out to
'eating bitterness'.
And so that's where the title of the book
comes from, and that's really--.
I didn't set off with this as a theme in mind,
in the beginning.
But as I talked to different migrants over
and over again, they, themselves, brought
this up as being the key to their ability
to survive in China, in urban China, for so
long.
And really it emerges in every chapter, all
the different ways that people have to change
and grow and develop and to persevere in order
to keep a place for themselves in this really
rapidly changing society.
So I want to give you a I want to give you
an overview of the stories in the book but
first I'm going to answer a few key questions
that give you a little bit of background of
migrants.
So the first one is who are China's rural
migrants?
And so people tend to think that they're the
lowest level of society, but that's generally
not the case.
Over time, they are increasingly more well
educated and increasingly younger.
So last year a full 70% of migrants were under
the age of 30 and 65% typically finished middle
school.
The thing, though, in China is that there
is only 9 years of compulsory education.
If you want to get into high school, you have
to pass a very competitive entrance exam and
you also have to pay for high school.
So in poor rural areas, less than 50% of people
will go onto high school.
So, for a lot of people, they end up in the
cities as migrants.
The next question is why do people come to
the cities?
Why are rural people coming to the cities?
So the obvious answer to this is that there's
a large and growing income gap in China.
So urban income is about three and a half
times higher than rural income.
And then also eastern income is about one
and a half times higher than western income.
To put this in perspective, so I live in Beijing
and for a very a very average two bedroom
house, with the ceiling is collapsing in our
apartment, but for a very average, [laughs]
it's not a fancy house, it's very average
two bedroom apartment, what I pay in rent
each month is more than a farmer in western
China will make in an entire year.
So that's a really significant driver pushing
people to the cities to look for jobs with
higher salaries.
And related to this is an issue of a lack
of land in China.
When China ended collectivized agriculture
in the late '70s and early, 80's they had
to do something with all of that land that
previous was collectivized.
So what they essentially did was every local
village government divvied up all their farmland
and every resident of that village received
a plot of land.
And this is essentially still the system that's
in place today.
If you're born as a rural resident in China,
at birth, you receive a plot of land and it's
not exactly yours, so you cannot sell it.
If you let the land go fallow, you'll lose
it and when you die, it goes back to the village
to be redistributed to the next generation.
But other than that, it's essentially yours
for life.
This is really, it's hard to sort of impress
how important this piece of land is to these
farmers.
It's really their main sort of social security.
They really value this land.
The problem comes, though, that that by the
time you divvy all the arable land in China
among seven to eight hundred million rural
residents, each person only gets about a sixth
of an acre of land.
So even if you assume a Chinese family of
four, that's still 673 times smaller than
the average American farm.
When you're talking about plots of land that
are so small, farming in China is really not
a viable lively hood.
It's more of a sustenance insurance plan.
It's just a way to make sure that you can
keep your family fed.
So anyone who really wants to do more than
just keep your family fed they typically have
to send at least one family member to the
cities to look for work as migrants.
And then I also want to look at what are some
of the difficulties that migrants face when
they arrive in the cities.
There's a lot of them.
I'll just go over them quickly.
The first one is working conditions.
They tend to be overworked.
70% or 80% will work seven days a week, 9,
10, 12, 15 hour days are very common.
Also, they tend to be underpaid.
And there was a lot of news in China a couple
years back that migrant salaries had risen
quickly and they're now within about $20 to
$30 of a college graduate starting salary.
And so, when this news came out what happened
is a lot of seventh graders, sixth, seventh,
eighth graders, started dropping out of school
because they thought "Oh I can go to the city
and make [laughs] about what a college graduate
makes."
But of course, what they're not really thinking
about is, is that a college graduate, one
their salaries is going to go up pretty steeply
over the course of their life, but also a
college graduate is not working seven days
a week, 16 hour days, 360 days a year.
If you look hour-by-hour, migrants are still
quite underpaid.
And then also in terms of living conditions,
so these City Villages are often built very
haphazardly, a lot of safety hazards there.
And also migrants they live in very small
spaces.
50% of migrants will live in eight square
meters or less, which is essentially a bed
with a walkway around it.
It's very small living space.
And then these villages also, because they're
people are so transient, there they have a
lot of social problems and crime.
And then there's difficulties in terms of
social conditions.
Many migrants they leave their kids back in
the village, their parents are back in the
village, sometimes, --in the book there's
one family--, where the wife is one city as
a migrant, the husband's in another city as
a migrant, and they have two daughters each
with a different relative in a different village.
This is very common that migrants, their families
are very split apart.
There's also a stigma among the urban population
that migrants and migrant children are sort
of lower quality, than the urban population.
And, I think also, I don't hear a lot of people
talk about this, but I think psychologically
it's also very difficult you come from a village
and you're living in this very new modern
city and you're helping to develop it and
yet you yourself feel like you don't have
any place there and you're not really a part
of what's happening.
So, I think psychologically, there's a lot
of difficulties.
Now the last one I want to talk about is probably
the biggest and hottest topic in China right
now in terms of migration and that has to
do with China's Hukou system or its household
registration system.
Essentially this is a system in which every
person, at birth, is ascribed to a location
in which they belong and you're labeled as
either an urban person or a rural person.
So in China, urban and rural are not just
adjectives, they're actually legal definitions.
And once you are, and it's not, I should say
it's not based on where you are born, because
then everybody would just go and have their
kids in Beijing, but it's based on where your
parents are registered.
And once you are registered as a rural person,
it's very difficult to change that registration
to a city registration.
The only really easy way to do that is to
go to college.
If you can get into college, you can change
your registration and become a full-fledged
urbanite and sort of seamlessly integrate
into society.
But in rural areas, less than 25% of kids
are going to have the opportunity to go to
college.
For most people, once you are born as a rural
person that's, that's it for life.
You are going to be officially a rural person.
In the beginning of this system, actually
China's had some version of this system on
and off for 2000 years, but the most recent
reincarnation was implemented by Mao in the
late '50s as a means of preventing people
from fleeing the countryside when collectivized
agriculture began.
At that time, you had to have a lot of, if
you wanted to leave where you were registered,
you needed a lot of permissions and it was
considered illegal to move about basically
without permission.
Today, they don't use the system in that way,
so people are free to move back and forth,
as they want.
What they do use the system for is to allocate
benefits.
Everybody in China is entitled to free education
for their children, to subsidized health care,
but you're only entitled to those things in
the location in which you are registered.
For migrants when they leave where they're
registered they come to the cities where they're
not registered they often their kids are turned
way from urban schools, they can't get healthcare,
they can't buy property, they can't get legal
protection.
So there's a, it's really created a bit of
a two class system and in many ways that,
although these migrants are not considered
illegal, they're treated in many ways similar
to illegal immigrants would be in other countries.
This is really emerging as a big problem in
China and that brings me back to the point
that migrants and the issues related to migration
are really emerging in China as the key domestic
challenge that the government has to face.
I think it's easy to throw big numbers when
you talk about China but if you think about
300 million people moving within the next
20 years that's basically like taking the
entire population of the US and having every
man woman and child leave wherever they are,
go to a new place, get a new job, find a new
place to live and, I think, if we try to do
that, obviously, I think it would probably
degenerate into chaos pretty quickly.
If you think about it from that perspective,
you can really see the enormity of the challenge
that is facing China right now and the potential
for things to go wrong at multiple levels.
I think, probably things going wrong might
be the expected norm when you're talking about
such fast and rap-, wide scale migration.
That really makes people like those that I'm
writing about in Eating Bitterness critical
to China's future.
I want to give you an overview of some of
the stories that you'll find in the book.
It's, the book starts actually with this family
of vegetable vendors who never intended to
immigrated to the city.
But about 12 years ago, well in the '90s I
should say, in the '90s this man he was doing
construction as a part time job in his village,
he was in an accident and was hospitalized
for more than two years and had to have multiple
surgeries.
And wracked up medical bills that would be
about $12,000 US dollars, but for a farmer
in rural China in the '90s that was an astronomical
amount that he could never really hope to
pay back on farming wages.
And so his wife left him and their one-year-old
daughter in the village with his mother and
went to the city to look for work.
Now they are reunited, that was about 12 years
before I met them and they are reunited now,
in Xi'an, and they work everyday from 3 A.M.
to 9 P.M., so 18-hour days, 7 days a week,
basically they take a day off for the Spring
Festival.
This is has been the last 12 years they have
been working like that.
What they told me is they do this with the
one goal in mind and that's that their daughter
doesn't have this same sort of tired existence
that they do.
That she'll have more skills to offer society
and something more to do with her life.
And there's also a chapter about young girls
who don't pass the high school entrance exams,
so right out of middle school, at 15, they
come to the cities looking for work and these
girls end up working in a chain of beauty
salons, which is really a new industry emerging
in western China.
This chain of beauty salons, it's very good
at holding up a picture of a very bright future
the girls can have if they work hard and find
a way to become managers in this company.
And they're always kind of saying, "You can
have a house and a car and you can become
a permanent urban resident."
The girls, for their part, they're really
eager to accomplish these things and yet they
feel sort of helpless and hopeless because,
as fairly poorly educated girls coming from
the countryside, they don't feel that they
ever really could become managers in a company
like this.
They live with this underlying fear that if
they don't get their act together and figure,
figure things out they may not have a permanent
place in the city.
They may end up going back to their villages
and being farmers like their parents.
This chapter, this is a very sort of common
thing that happens to young people who come
to cities.
So this is that chapter.
Then there's a chapter about a family who
is actually the one of the original family
of farmers in the City Village of Gan Jia
Zhai and they lost their land when the high
tech zone was built.
Probably you've followed the news you've seen
there's been a lot of protests in China in
the last year.
I think there's about 100 thousand protests
last year about farmers who've had their land
unfairly grabbed from them, or they've been
not well compensated for their land.
That's a serious problem in China.
But I've never seen anyone really talking
about the other side of the picture, which
is actually more common, which is farmers
are paid well for their land.
I don't think that plays as catchy of a headline,
so you don't see it very often.
In all the villages that I've been to, most
farmers are sort of eagerly awaiting for the
day when the city might expand out to their
village because they know that they'll make
more money, that they'll get paid more money
for their land than they could ever make farming
their land.
It's sort of seen like a lottery ticket, if
you can if the city moves out to your village.
This family, when their farmland was bought
from them in the '90s to make way for the
high tech zone, at that time in China, an
extremely wealthy person was not called a
millionaire, they were called a ten thousandaire.
If you had, ten thousand Renminbi at that
time you were extremely wealthy.
They made at that time 50,000, they got paid
50,000 Renminbi for their land, so they were
ten thousandaires five times over.
[laughs] On top of that, when I met them,
by renting out rooms in their home they made
about 10,000 Renminbi in income a month.
At that time, a software programmer in the
high tech zone would make about 3,000.
So financially, they are very set.
What happens, and this is extremely common
in this village and I've seen this in many
City Villages, is that now they have, they
are financially secure but they don't have
anything to do and they don't really have
a lot of other skills, skill sets so idleness
and addiction really sort of seep in and so
this man, he's been addicted to mahjong for
the last 20 years.
He told me it's his full time occupation.
It's really sad in some ways and, in fact
in this village, many people told me that
when they lost their land the farmers now,
some people turn to Buddhism, like everyone
was looking for something to occupy their
time.
So some people turn to Buddhism, some people
turn to gambling, but then they said, "The
most pitiful of us are those who didn't find
anything and we still don't know what to do
with our time."
I think this chapter's pretty important because
it shows the other side of the picture in
terms of what happens when China's farmers
who lose their land to urbanization are paid
well.
There's a whole new set of social issues that
really creep in to these areas.
The book ends with the story of a 32 year
old, second grade dropout, who came to Xi'an
essentially destitute but with in about five
years amassed a small empire of convenience
stores and health clinics and fitness stores,
fitness centers and really he's blown past
all the typical obstacles that would be in
a migrant's path.
But he finds himself more lonely and isolated
than he ever was as a poor man.
He really, he has this desire to turn his
sight away from his own material prosperity
and he wants to become a philanthropist.
But he doesn't tell anybody this because he
feels like, in Chinese society today, nobody
could really understand that desire and they
would sort of laugh at him and say "Stop being
silly, just focus on getting more rich" basically.
I was really drawn to this story not just
because it's sort of a typical rags to riches
story but I think that it's really emblematic
of the direction that modern China is headed.
Because when China started its opening and
reform policies 30 years ago, people had this
underlying concept that first, you have to
focus on material prosperity, you have to
have a strong material foundation and then
you can think about other things.
And in fact, many people still have this idea
today.
Things that weren't sort of directly related
to material prosperity were seen as distractions.
But today China's changed a lot in the last
30 years and there are a lot of people now
who are becoming quite wealthy and who are
reaching those material dreams that they set
out for themselves, or are surpassing them.
You see in Chinese cities now a real restlessness
setting in as people sort of wondering what
else is there to life beyond just having a
strong material foundation.
You see a rise of things that previously everyone
thought were distractions like religion or
social activism, environmentalism, philanthropy,
these things are gradually on the rise now
in China.
I think that while most migrants aren't going
to become as successful as this man, I mean,
most urbanites aren't even going to become
as successful as this man has become.
Right now, the GDP in China is growing so
fast that the it's essentially doubling every
seven years.
Everybody is seeing changes in their lifestyles.
Everyone, not evenly obviously, but everyone
is seeing improvements.
I think that at some point these migrants
who, for decades, have basically been sort
of blindly pushing ahead and enduring difficulties,
eating bitterness, without really having many
demands or expectations, at some point people
are going to stop and sort of reassess that
mentality and want more out of life and want
more out of their labor.
You do see this happening already in China
especially among the younger generation that
they're willing to endure difficulties and
eat bitterness but only without it being sort
of a temporary means to a more comfortable
end.
This is really a challenge to China because
its whole development model has sort of relied
on that fact that people are willing and able
to endure a lot without having a lot of expectations
and without complaining.
This is a challenge to China as it moves forward.
So that's where the book ends and that's where
I'd like to end today.
So essentially the book obviously is of interest
to anyone who is interested in China or urbanization,
migration, social transformation, development.
But I think over and above that, it's a work
of literary non-fiction that is really a human
story in the end.
The term 'eating bitterness' is a Chinese
term, but it's obviously not an exclusively
Chinese quality, it's a human quality that
you see over and over in history as the human
spirit sort of rises up and overcomes what
seems to be insurmountable obstacles.
In this book, every chapter has sort of tragedies
that people face yet also a lot of triumph
as they overcome the difficulties.
That's where I will end and if anybody has
any questions we can open it up for questions.
The pollution in Xi'an was so bad when I was
there, when I first moved there, where I lived
in my apartment, there was no tall buildings
they were all being built in the distance.
So I could look out in the distance and for
a year and half I lived there, not knowing
that one day there was a clear blue sky day
and suddenly I saw this huge mountain range
right out my window that I had no idea existed
for a year and half.
[laughs] The pollution there was very terrible.
I think it's still pretty bad.
Now I live in Beijing and people who haven't
lived in Xi'an think Beijing pollution is
terrible, but I'm like "it's blue sky, at
least 50% of the time."
Yeah, I haven't been there too often in the
last few years, but I think it's still pretty.
Yeah, that's definitely in Chinese there's
a term called the after '80s generation.
Essentially anybody born after 1980 has only
grown up in China's economic good times.
It's actually derog-, it's a slightly derogatory
term that the older generation will use to
sort of say, "Oh, those kids born after 1980,
they don't really know how to endure difficulty,
they never really faced sort of deprivation
and starvation and all these things that the
older generations have gone through."
Yeah, their work ethic is definitely very
different and I think it's a big challenge
for the companies that employ them because
their not sort of willing to just go through
so many difficulties without, for example
people don't want to migrate as far.
They're having more and more difficulties
getting people to migrate to the east, because
a lot of migration happens from west to east,
obviously, because of the income gap.
There definitely it's causing a lot of changes
in the way migrants work in China.
Yeah, the probably the biggest thing the government
is doing is they're trying to expand that
education system.
And, in fact, they've really spent the last
decade trying to rapidly expand the education
system.
If you look back in the 1990s, only about
3% of students could get into college because
there just wasn't enough universities at that
time.
Today it's about 25% can get into college.
Still that's low but considering they went
from 4 to 25% in a decade and also the same
with high schools, that they have not enough
high schools for so many kids and so the first
thing they are trying to do is have more schools
and allow more people to have higher levels
of education so they can do more skilled jobs
in the future.
Also, this whole issue of the household registration
system, there's been a lot of pressure on
China to get rid of that system, do something
about that.
But it's interesting because in the places
where they've had, in cities where they've
had pilot programs to get rid of that system,
two things have happened.
One is that a lot of cities who offered urban
benefits to the migrant population, they went
bankrupt pretty quickly because they just
didn't have the capacity to offer benefits
to so many more people.
But the other thing that's happened is, in
western China for example, I forgot if it's
in Chengdu or Chongqing, but in western China,
one city had this policy that they wanted
to allow 10 million migrants to trade in their
rural registration for an urban registration
so they could become official city residents.
But within, in the first year of that program,
they only had a few thousand takers.
And this actually corresponds with what I
saw when I was interviewing people that many
migrants said to me, "We don't have many skills,
we do physical manual labor and at some point
our bodies are going to break down.
We're going to get old, we're going to get
injured, something.
And if we traded in, because your land is
tied with that rural registration, if you
give up your rural registration, you give
up your land."
If they trade in that rural registration for
an urban registration, they said, "Some point
when my body breaks down, how can I support
my life in the cities.
I don't have enough skill to find another
kind of job."
Most migrants right now, at least, are not
willing to trade in that piece of land for
ur-, official urban status, where you get
more benefits.
So it's a quandary for the government, because
they have this pressure to get rid of this
system and yet the people who everyone's advocating
for, aren't really interested in giving up
their rural residency right now.
Well, that's a good question; I wouldn't call
it phenomenal success.
I think China is a country with a lot of contradictions.
You see, for example, in the last 30 years,
600 million people were raised out of poverty.
You see an emergence of a really wealthy class
now.
But yet at the same time there are still people
who are living in a very poor situations.
So it's kind of a mixed bag, I think, in terms
of China.
But overall, I think, yeah, things have gone
pretty smoothly for China.
I think partly because people have such a
work ethic.
The other day when I said somewhere that "China
has lifted 600 million people out of poverty."
And someone said, "No, no, no.
600 million people in China lifted themselves
out of poverty."
So I think that partly it is, that was a good
distinction, because partly it is just the
hard work ethic that people have.
They really have helped the country to move
forward so quickly.
So it's going to be interesting as this younger
generation has a very different sort of mindset
and work ethic, to see what's going to happen.
There have been in the recent years, there've
been some small-scale protests that have happened.
I think the main, one of the main ones people
protests about is they want their kids to
be able to have education in the cities.
Socially, families being split up is not a
good policy and even family who bring their
kids to the city, they can only bring them
there for primarily school because if you
want to take the test to get into high school,
you have to go back to the place where you're
registered, your household, you're registered
and take the test there.
Yes, the big that people are sort of unhappy
about is the situation with their children.
And also in factories, for example, sometimes
people don't get paid on time, or they don't
get paid for months.
I've heard of protests about things like that.
But I haven't seen anything sort of large
scale happening.
I think that is because people, one: they
have this work ethic to just endure, but also
I think there's there's a bit of the collective
mentality in China that still is there.
People, you often will hear people who will
say, "I personally don't like, this situation,
or that situation, but I know that it's good
for China, or I know that it's helping China
to advance."
People are sort of willing to put their own
personal happiness or satisfaction aside for
what they perceive to be the good of the country.
Yeah, I think it's probably the local governments
who don't feel equipped to offer benefits
on such a wide scale.
In some cities, like in Shanghai, 40% of the
population is migrant population.
If you are suddenly going to offer them benefits
as well, I think the local governments feel
like they don't know how to deal with that,
or they are not willing to deal with that
right now.
Yeah, I think that's true, for example in
that chapter that I write about the landless
landlords, the people who became wealthy when
their land was bought out.
They made the comment that in that City Village
now, the people who collect the trash or do
the recycling or do any of those sort of jobs,
none of them are the local people anymore,
because they said, "Once people have sort
of financial stability, no one's willing to
do those jobs anymore."
The people who do those jobs in a City Village
like that will all also be migrants and so
there's definitely even among that population
there's the different classes that emerged.
Yeah, it, it, I don't know how that is going
to play out in the future, but there definitely
is this group of people who when their land
is bought up they become extremely wealthy
and a whole bunch of social problems follow
that.
Well, I should say at first that, that's what
happened in the factories in the south.
In my book, I don't write about factory workers
because, really, they are something of a migrant
subculture.
If you work in a factory, you work there,
you're given a dormitory on the factory grounds,
you eat in the factory cafeterias, they often
have movie theaters and bowling alleys, and
it's a whole universe into itself.
A lot of times the factories might have 70,000
employees, so we're talking about, it's basically
a city.
So those migrants are really sort of isolated
from the larger society, so I didn't write
about those, so I don't know so much about
the conditions in factories.
What I will say, this isn't a justification
for any abuses that happened in those factories,
but that a lot of the migrants that I wrote
about, who are self employed, they still choose
to live almost identically to the factory
workers.
For example, that family of vegetable vendors,
on their own accord they choose to work 18-hour
days and they live in what's essentially a
one car garage with no windows.
There's a room for two beds and when they
want to eat, they turn a crate on its side
and it's sort of a makeshift table.
There's no plumbing, they cook in the hallways,
that kind of thing.
Originally, as I got to know them, coming
from my western perspective, I assumed that
they're just destitute, like they are doing
this because they have other options in life.
But as I got to know them, it turns out, no.
In China, the savings rate is between 30 and
40%, but migrants try to be as close to 100%
as they can.
And so it's hard coming from America where
the, I think it's a negative savings rate,
if I'm not mistaken, [laughter] to kind of
wrap your mind around the fact that people
will be willing to not just live at their
means, but way below their means.
So this family, actually, they've been saving
money for years and to have enough money to
build something of a mansion back in the countryside
and pay for their parents, as they're getting
older and their kids' education and all of
these things.
I think it's it's important to sort of realize
that migrants aren't seeing their own reality
as maybe we are viewing it and hearing about
it in the media.
I think there are factories were conditions
are bad, but from what I understand, in factories
where they try to make conditions better,
so they cut the overtime for example, people
will quit because they're there exactly for
the expressly for the purpose of making money
and even if this is a factory with better
conditions, if it doesn't give them enough
hours so they can make as much money as possible,
they'll quit and go to a worse factory with
longer hours so they can make more money.
Yeah, it's interesting to think about it from
their perspective and their motivations.
Yeah, that's a big concern in China, because
China actually, from the beginning, had a
lack of arable land considering its size.
Then as more and more farmland gets bought
up, obviously, that's a concern.
The central government has tried to put a
curb on the local government's ability to
take farm land, not always with great success
because local governments buying up farmland
and turning them into urban development that's
sort of the local government's major, major
income source in lots of areas.
In terms of having enough people to do the
farming, so the land is an issue, but in terms
of the actual movement of people China right
now has way too many rural people considering
now that it's mechanized agriculture, they
don't need 700 million people.
So they, actually as people leave the villages,
it's very good for farming because then fewer
people left in the rural areas can have bigger
plots of land, make a salary that's somewhat
more comparable to an urban salary.
Definitely, that the literacy rate in China,
I think in the 80s, like if you go back to
like the 1950s it was less than 50% and the
80s it was about 60% and today it's about
94% literacy, so most people can read, of
course.
And if you look at just the young population,
it's about 99% literacy.
So these people, in this village, they definitely
all could read, they went to middle school,
that family that man who's addicted to Mahjong.
But I think that there's a stereotype at least
in this province of China that the men are
sort of, well, OK, the women will say that
the men are lazy.
The women tend to be more the go-getters.
There is also a chapter where, in the book,
where the wife is really wanting to sort of
work her way up and become this official urban
resident and get a house and all these things
and the husband is kind of, like "We're fine.
Life is good.
You know, I can play pool all day and you
know, why do we need to work so hard?"
There's a bit of that that you see that people
are just sort of like, "I have money now,
what do I need to sort of keep working."
So people don't have higher aspirations for
themselves.
But they definitely could and a few people
do, but overall there tends to be sort of
this lethargy that sort of sinks in.
OK, well thank you so much everybody for coming.
It's been great.
[Applause]